[Music]
I spent six years of my career being
called things like bag of milk baby cow
yeah I all ever felt self-conscious that
I was like anyone who's gonna take the
time to say something negative up my
weight on the internet wasn't someone I
was particularly keen to impress anyway
Lena Dunham is taking body critics to
task the girls star turned heads last
week when she stepped out as celeb
trainer to see Anderson studio opening
in New York City looking noticeably
thinner I got at least whipping like
you're a hypocrite I thought you were
body-positive I thought you were a
person who embraced bodies of all sizes
and I was like I do I just understand
that my bodies change we live a long
time things happen Lena pointed out to
Ellen the double standard women in the
public eye face I was frustrated by it
because I was like eat it really was
evidence that as a woman in Hollywood
you just can't win what Lena is saying
is that is that everyone is focused on
the least interesting thing about her
Lena's pal America Ferrera praised her
when et caught up with the superstore
star at the hrc gala America says she
too has been victim to body shame errs
whether or not she's gaining or losing
weight in a good way or a bad way has
nothing to do with her Worth and her
value Lena change the conversation we
have to be willing to take our voices
and the spotlight that is on us and flip
the script and have the conversation we
want to be having about our bodies and
our voices and our talents
[Music]
you